Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has signed
a bill into law that will stop Florida
minor league baseball players from
earning minimum wage there is an
exception for minor league baseball
players where they don't have to be paid
the minimum wage the argument that's
being made is the following argument
minor league baseball players get free
housing free transportation and free
breakfast Just Breakfast they're not
going to lunch and dinner but they get
free breakfast as well as the
opportunity if they make it to the major
leagues to make multi-generational
wealth and therefore
they should be exempt from the laws of
minimum wage I disagree with this 100
percent